[Music]
did you know that
one in three older adults will die from
alzheimer's disease or another type of
dementia
this disease has a tragic effect on many
lives
and current research still can't fully
explain it
however scientists do know that there
are many
genetic social and environmental factors
that
influence a person's susceptibility to
develop alzheimer's disease
alzheimer's disease is one of the most
common forms of dementia
a chronic disorder of mental processes
caused by brain disease or injury
and mocked by memory disorders
personality changes
and impaired reasoning alzheimer's
disease
is a progressive neurodegenerative
disease that leads to memory loss and
cognitive decline
often preventing the affected individual
from carrying out simple day-to-day
tasks
people with alzheimer's disease may
experience mood changes
find it difficult to learn new
information and become unable to
recognize friends and family
in a brain suffering from alzheimer's
disease a large number of neurons die
resulting in tissue loss that can be
seen on a brain scan
some researchers believe that two
protein complexes
contribute to this widespread neuron
death neurofibrillary tangles
and amyloid plaques in a diseased brain
neurofibrillary tangles make it harder
for neurons to receive nutrients
and send signals to each other the
neurofibrillary tangles
are composed of tau protein in a healthy
brain
tau protein forms microtubules which are
cell structures
that transport nutrients and support the
cytoskeleton
meanwhile amyloid plaques are made of a
protein called beta amyloid
a part of the larger amyloid precursor
protein
beta amyloid is cut from amyloid
precursor protein
and degraded outside the cell this
process
is facilitated by a polypo protein e or
apoe
which helps break down beta amyloid the
genome of any given individual
can contain one of three isoforms or
variations of apoe
of these isoforms apoe4 is the least
effective at cleaving beta amyloid
beta amyloid accumulates due to its
chemical stickiness
resulting in protein aggregates and
plaque formation
these plaques damage neurons and lead to
cell death
having the apoe4 gene is an example of a
genetic risk factor
the expression of apoe4 increases the
likelihood of beta-amyloid aggregates
thereby increasing the risk of
developing alzheimer's disease
besides genetics there are other factors
that contribute to someone's
susceptibility to alzheimer's disease
there's a concept called reserve that
relates life experiences like
exercise diet and education with the
prevalence of age-related brain changes
and pathological changes
like those observed in dementia and
alzheimer's disease
there is brain reserve which refers to
the physiological characteristics of the
brain
is it large or small how many neurons
and synapses are there
these are physical features that can
affect pathology
then there is cognitive reserve which
refers to the brain's ability to rewire
itself
and find alternative ways to perform a
function if the original pathway is
damaged
a person with a high cognitive reserve
can cope better with brain damage
than a person with low cognitive reserve
the concept of cognitive reserve
has been linked to education and
occupational attainment
based on epidemiological studies people
with more education
and greater occupational attainment are
believed to have a higher cognitive
reserve and they have demonstrated
reduced susceptibility to alzheimer's
disease
it's also believed that a high cognitive
reserve can delay the onset of clinical
pathology
so the cognitive symptoms of alzheimer's
disease or other forms of dementia
will manifest when the pathology is more
severe
however it's been observed that patients
with a high cognitive reserve
have a more rapid decline in cognitive
function when their brain can no longer
tolerate the level of brain
injury besides education research shows
a link
between low socioeconomic status early
in life
and developing alzheimer's disease later
in life low-income populations in
general
have less access to health care and are
more likely to have unhealthy lifestyle
behaviors
like smoking unhealthy eating and not
exercising
all of which can contribute to the
development of alzheimer's disease
and other chronic diseases such as
obesity and diabetes
there are still a lot of unknown factors
that can cause alzheimer's disease
there are questions surrounding the
effect of environmental toxins
like metals and air pollution the effect
of the microbiome that coexists inside
our bodies
and the role of the immune system as
scientists work to uncover the science
behind alzheimer's disease to develop a
cure
a lot of research is also being invested
into finding better ways to care for
patients to ease the burden alzheimer's
disease has on them
and their families
[Music]
you